(Transcrito por TurboScribe. Atualize para Ilimitado para remover esta mensagem.) Acabamos de falar na aula anterior sobre o
que acontece quando existe uma ação judicial prévia
ao leilão, quando o devedor fiduciário está questionando
algo que está levando aquele imóvel a leilão.
A gente falou que existe a evicção de
direitos e que o arrematante vai ficar amparado
pela evicção e vai ter a garantia do
que seu valor vai ser restituído pelo índice
de correção monetária explícito no edital daquele leilão.
Que isso só não vai acontecer caso ocorra
uma exceção de que se o arrematante for
informado previamente de que existem aquelas ações, que
ele pode assumir o risco daquelas ações.
E agora a gente vai falar sobre o
que acontece se após o leilão, se após
a arrematação daquele imóvel em leilão excrediticial, o
devedor entrar com o processo tentando anular aquele
leilão.
Em primeiro lugar, queria falar que nesse caso
aqui, também ocorre a chamada garantia da evicção
de direitos, só que aqui ainda tem uma
ressalva.
Como essa ação só vai existir após o
leilão, nem tem como o arrematante ser responsabilizado
por assumir aquele risco.
Afinal de contas, para que o arrematante assuma
o risco de um processo que existe, ele
tem que ser previamente informado daquele processo.
E aqui no nosso caso dessa aula especificamente,
o processo só seria movido após a arrematação
em leilão excrediticial.
Então, por óbvio, não tem como o arrematante
assumir o risco de alguma coisa que ainda
nem existe.
Então, aqui nesse caso, seria perfeitamente possível a
evicção de direitos sem qualquer ressalva.
Caso o leilão seja anulado após a arrematação,
o arrematante faz jus, sim, a receber tudo
aquilo que pagou devidamente corrigido.
Mas aqui queria deixar uma observação que é
muito importante.
O que que a nossa lei fala sobre
qualquer ação movida após a arrematação?
A lei protege muito o arrematante.
A lei diz que qualquer alegação do devedor
tentando anular aquele leilão vai ser resolvida em
perdas e danos, exceto falta de notificação do
devedor para purgar a mora e falta de
notificação do devedor para informar as datas do
leilão.
Então vamos lá, vamos explicar o que isso
aqui significa.
A gente já sabe que no curso que
o devedor tem que ser notificado para purgar
a mora, que é oficialmente falar que aquele
devedor está devendo e abrir ali um prazo
de 15 dias para que ele pague aquilo
que ele está devendo.
Se ele não pagar, vai ocorrer a consolidação
da propriedade em nome do credor fiduciário e
o credor fiduciário obrigatoriamente vai ter que realizar
primeiro e segundo leilão.
A gente também já sabe aqui no curso
que é obrigatório que o devedor fiduciante seja
notificado da data do primeiro e do segundo
leilão.
Por que mesmo que é obrigatório que ele
seja notificado da data do primeiro e do
segundo leilão?
Porque o devedor fiduciante tem no primeiro leilão
e no segundo leilão direito de preferência para
arrematar aquele bem se ele quitar a integralidade
daquele contrato.
A gente também já falou que é muito
difícil que o devedor exerça esse direito de
preferência, afinal de contas ele não tinha um
pequeno valor quando ele foi constituído em mora.
Como é que do nada ele vai aparecer
com aquele valor integral daquele contrato que com
certeza vai ser muito maior do que aqueles
valores iniciais que ele estava devendo.
Mas enfim, essas são os requisitos da lei.
Tem que notificar para purgar a mora e
tem que notificar do primeiro e do segundo
leilão.
A notificação para purgar a mora, o próprio
cartório de registro de imóveis competente para aquele
imóvel vai certificar ali que realmente ocorreu a
notificação do devedor, que ele foi constituído em
mora, que abriu o prazo para ele pagar
o que ele estava devendo e que ele
não pagou.
Então, por isso, foi realizada a consolidação da
propriedade em nome do credor fiduciário.
Essa primeira notificação então vai ficar ali registrada
na própria matrícula do imóvel.
Agora, a gente também viu que a notificação
do primeiro e do segundo leilão, via de
regra, os leiloeiros não colocam na página do
imóvel.
Então, vai ser necessário que você entre em
contato diretamente com o leiloeiro e peça para
que ele envie esses comprovantes, porque isso é
uma garantia para que você possa participar daquele
leilão.
Essa é a única alegação que, de fato,
pode anular um leilão e um arrematante ele
ficar sem o bem sendo restituído dos valores
que ele pagou.
O que acontece em qualquer outra alegação?
Qualquer outra alegação, a lei diz que vai
ser resolvida em perdas e danos.
O que seria qualquer outra alegação?
Tem muito devedor fiduciante que, após o leilão,
pede para que o leilão seja anulado, alegando
que os juros daquele contrato eram juros abusivos,
que deveriam incidir juros menores ou qualquer outra
questão ali do contrato de alienação fiduciária.
Todas essas questões serão resolvidas em perdas e
danos.
O que significa falar que vai ser resolvido
em perdas e danos?
Significa falar que, caso ocorra esse processo do
devedor fiduciante contra o credor fiduciário e, ao
final do processo, realmente a justiça entenda que
o credor fiduciário cometeu algum erro para levar
aquele imóvel a leilão, que o credor fiduciário
vai ter que pagar o devedor fiduciante em
dinheiro e não mais com o imóvel.
O arrematante vai continuar com o imóvel, vai
ser emitido na posse tranquilamente e isso nada
vai ter relação com o arrematante.
Então, qualquer alegação do devedor para anular um
leilão, exceto a falta de notificação do primeiro
e do segundo leilão, vai ser resolvida em
perdas e danos.
Se, ao final do processo, a justiça entender
que realmente o credor fiduciário agiu de forma
errada, o credor fiduciário vai pagar algum valor
em dinheiro para aquele devedor fiduciante e isso
nada terá relação com o arrematante.
O arrematante vai continuar normalmente com o imóvel
que ele arrematou e a emissão na posse
também ocorre normalmente.
Isso é o que a lei diz e
isso também é o que a jurisprudência diz.
O que é jurisprudência?
Jurisprudência é um conjunto de normas sobre determinado
assunto que indica o entendimento dos criminais sobre
aquele determinado assunto.
Então, a jurisprudência demonstra para qualquer interessado qual
é o entendimento do tribunal sobre aquele determinado
assunto.
E a jurisprudência, nesse nosso caso específico, também
diz que caso ocorra uma ação do devedor
após a finalização do leilão excrediticial, nada impede
a posse do arrematante.
Então, vamos lá.
O arrematante, ele tentou primeiro aquela desocupação voluntária,
não conseguiu, realmente precisou ingressar com uma ação
de emissão na posse.
Então, vai existir ação de emissão na posse
do arrematante.
Do outro lado, o devedor, ele quer alegar
algum erro naquele procedimento que levou o imóvel
ao leilão.
Ele pode falar que o valor da dívida
dele não era o que o banco colocou
ali como o valor do segundo leilão, que
o valor da dívida era menor, porque naquele
contrato, por exemplo, ele alega que existiram juros
abusivos.
Então, arrematante entrou com ação de emissão na
posse, devedor entrou com uma ação questionando aquele
leilão.
O que a jurisprudência diz?
A ação de emissão na posse vai ocorrer
normalmente.
Ela não vai ser paralisada por existir essa
ação no devedor.
Então, o arrematante, ele vai ser emitido na
posse, ele vai tomar posse daquele imóvel normalmente.
E se ao final dessa ação, aqui do
devedor, o Poder Judiciário falar que realmente aconteceu
um erro, que o credor judiciário cobrou algo
que ele não poderia ter cobrado, o credor
fiduciário vai ser condenado a indenizar o devedor
fiduciante em perdas e danos.
Isso é, com o dinheiro, nada mais tem
relação com o imóvel.
Eu separei aqui alguns julgados que falam exatamente
isso que a gente acabou de falar para
você realmente observar que isso é uma jurisprudência
consolidada que protege bastante o arrematante.
Então, vamos lá.
Primeiro julgado que eu coloquei aqui é um
julgado do STJ.
O STJ é o Superior Tribunal de Justiça
e é quem tem a última palavra sobre
matérias não constitucionais, porque a matéria constitucional é
analisada pelo STF.
Então, todas as matérias infraconstitucionais, a última palavra
é do STJ.
E o STJ, ele tem esse entendimento consolidado
que eu acabei de falar aqui pra vocês.
Então, primeiro julgado STJ, terceira turma, data de
julgamento 2017.
O que interessa pra gente aqui é o
ponto 3.
Então, vamos ler o ponto 3 desse julgado.
Essa corte traçou orientação no sentido de que
o artigo 265 do Código de Processo Civil
de 1973 não impõe o sobrestamento da ação
de missão na posse enquanto se discute em
outra demanda a anulação do ato de transferência
de domínio.
Então, o que significa aqui?
A ação de missão na posse não vai
ser sobrestada por outra ação que está discutindo
o domínio daquele imóvel.
Sobrestada é paralisada pra esperar o resultado daquela
outra ação.
E anulação de transferência de domínio seria realmente
tentar anular a consolidação da propriedade em nome
do credor fiduciário.
Porque veja, quando o credor fiduciário, ele realiza
a consolidação da propriedade em seu nome, o
domínio foi transferido pra ele.
Então, isso é realmente uma transferência de domínio.
Passou do campo do devedor pro campo do
credor aquele imóvel.
Então, tentar anular essa transferência seria tentar anular
a própria consolidação da propriedade.
Isso aí não tem qualquer implicação no prosseguimento
da ação de missão na posse do arrematante.
Uma observação, aqui esse julgado é de 2017
e ele está fazendo referência ao Código de
Processo Civil de 1973.
O Código de Processo Civil que está em
vigência hoje em dia é o Código de
Processo Civil de 2015, que apesar de ser
de 2015, entrou em vigência em 2016, mas
como ele foi elaborado em 2015, fica com
esse ano da elaboração dele.
Isso acontece em qualquer tribunal.
Quando um tribunal, ele consolida o entendimento, não
interessa depois se o número da lei mudou,
se a lei está expulando algo de forma
contrária.
Ele vai continuar citando o entendimento que ele
formulou lá atrás, antes da aquela lei ser
modificada.
Então, o STJ, ele tem esse entendimento muito
antigo, muito antes da entrada do Código de
Processo Civil de 2015 e, mesmo assim, ele
continua citando o código passado e não tem
qualquer problema nisso, o entendimento é o mesmo,
independente da aplicação do código.
Coloquei aqui um outro julgado, também do STJ,
já é um julgado mais recente de 2019
e é de outra turma.
Então, você veja que realmente esse entendimento é
completamente consolidado ali no âmbito do STJ e
de todos os demais tribunais do país.
O que interessa pra gente aqui é o
ponto 1, o STJ possui entendimento consolidado de
que o artigo 265 do Código de Processo
Civil de 1973 não impõe o sobrestamento de
ação de emissão na posse enquanto se discute
em outro feito a anulação de transferência de
domínio.
É exatamente a mesma passagem que a gente
acabou de estudar.
Por que isso acontece?
Porque realmente o entendimento é consolidado.
Então, quando vai aplicar entendimento, eles aplicam literalmente
o que ficou decidido.
E repare que, entre parênteses, tem um julgado,
o nome de um ministro e a data
que foi publicada no Diário de Justiça.
Então, esse entendimento aqui, ele ocorre desde 1998.
É algo muito pacífico, é algo antigo que,
até hoje, é aplicado para trazer segurança ao
arrematante.
Continuei aqui, coloquei um julgado do Tribunal de
Justiça de São Paulo.
É uma apelação civil que diz sobre a
ação de emissão na posse, sentença de procedência
tornando definitiva a emissão na posse do imóvel.
Recurso do réu, ou seja, provavelmente o devedor
que está perdendo aquele imóvel.
Esse recurso não foi acolhido.
Ele tinha tese defensiva fundada em irregularidade no
leilão extrajudicial.
O que o tribunal falou?
Que essa tese defensiva, tentando anular o leilão
extrajudicial, é matéria estranha ao adquirente do imóvel.
Quem é que adquiriu aquele imóvel?
O arrematante.
A emissão na posse é de rigor, ou
seja, qualquer alegação do devedor contra o credor
judiciário, nada tem relação com o arrematante.
O arrematante faz jus a ter a sua
emissão na posse, inclusive ali de ter o
pedido analisado de forma liminar.
Isso é muito importante.
Você tem que ter em mente sempre que
o arrematante é terceiro de boa-fé, que
ingressou naquela relação para criar um benefício.
Qual é o benefício?
Extinguir a dívida daquele devedor.
Afinal de contas, o valor da arrematação serve
exatamente para isso, para acabar com a dívida
do aquele devedor.
Então o arrematante é um terceiro de boa
-fé.
Ele não tem nada a ver com a
relação entre credor e devedor fiduciante.
E aí eu ainda coloquei mais um julgado
aqui do Tribunal de Justiça do Rio Grande
do Sul, que fala a mesma coisa.
Ação de emissão na posse, arrematação escrajudicial, ação
revisional e ação anulatória proposta pelo réu pendente
de julgamento perante a Justiça Federal.
Suspensão da ação de emissão na posse, impossibilidade,
sentença de procedência mantida.
E aí o tribunal fala a existência da
ação revisional e ou anulatória da arrematação junto
à Justiça Federal proposta pela réu devedora fiduciante,
imora a Constituição Financeira, de regra não impossibilita
o julgamento da ação de emissão na posse
proposta pelo arrematante do bem perante a Justiça
Comum.
É a mesma coisa que a gente acabou
de falar.
Essa devedora fiduciante aqui, ela devia para a
Caixa.
Como é que eu sei que é Caixa?
Porque a Caixa, ela está vinculada ao Governo
Federal.
Então, necessariamente, ela deve ser julgada na Justiça
Federal, enquanto os outros bancos seriam julgados na
Justiça Estadual, a Justiça Comum.
O que a gente vê aqui nesse julgado
do Tribunal de Justiça do Rio Grande do
Sul?
Que existia um processo na Justiça Federal e
um processo na Justiça Estadual.
O arrematante, ele arrematou aquele imóvel, entrou com
o processo na Justiça Estadual.
Afinal de contas, é uma relação entre arrematante
e devedor.
Nada teria relação com o credor fiduciário.
Nesse caso desse exemplo aqui, o credor fiduciário
é a Caixa Econômica Federal.
Como é que a gente sabe que é
a Caixa Econômica Federal?
Porque o processo que a devedora fiduciante moveu
contra o credor fiduciário foi movido na Justiça
Federal.
E a Caixa Econômica Federal, ela é vinculada
ao Governo Federal e, necessariamente, deve ser julgada
pela Justiça Federal.
Então, o que aconteceu nesse caso?
O arrematante arrematou o imóvel em leilão excrediticial,
entrou com a ação de emissão na posse
na Justiça Comum, na Justiça Estadual.
Ao mesmo tempo, a devedora fiduciante entrou com
uma ação na Justiça Federal tentando anular o
leilão e tentando fazer a revisão daquele contrato
de alienação fiduciária.
O que a Justiça Comum falou?
Não interessa aquele processo lá na Justiça Federal.
A emissão na posse vai acontecer normalmente em
favor do arrematante.
Depois, se a Justiça Federal realmente julgar que
ocorreu um erro, que foram cobrados juros maiores
do que o que deviam ou qualquer outra
coisa do tipo, a caixa vai indenizar aquela
devedora em dinheiro.
Nada vai ter relação com aquele imóvel mais.
Eu trouxe aqui julgados do STJ, Tribunal de
Justiça de São Paulo e Tribunal de Justiça
do Rio Grande do Sul.
Mas você precisa saber que esse entendimento é
consolidado no Brasil inteiro.
É porque seria realmente muito massivo fazer uma
aula botando julgado de todos os estados do
país.
Então, a gente aqui consolida o entendimento principalmente
pelo STJ, que é o tribunal superior a
qualquer tribunal estadual e fala com o entendimento
do STJ.
Esse entendimento do STJ está sendo seguido por
todos os criminais do Brasil.
É realmente uma garantia para o arrematante.
O que você precisa saber sobre arrematante?
O arrematante é um terceiro de boa-fé
que ingressou naquela relação para fazer benefício.
Qual é o benefício do arrematante num leilão
ex-prejudicial?
O valor que o arrematante pagou por aquela
arrematação vai ser usado para extinguir a dívida
do devedor.
Então, o arrematante causa um bem ao credor,
que vai receber o que lhe era devido,
e ao devedor, que nada mais vai dever
ao credor.
Então, tenha sempre isso em mente.
Como o arrematante é um terceiro de boa
-fé, a lei protege bastante o arrematante.
Mas também saiba que se, por acaso, numa
eventualidade, você participar de um leilão, se o
leilão for anulado pela justiça, você fará just
a evicção de direitos e receberá tudo o
que você pagou devidamente corrigido.